Sophie oui vous avez vu une interview
incroyable dans Ici Paris vous avez
évoqué avoir été victime d'un viol à
l'âge de 8 ans par un animateur radio et
malgré son traumatisme malgré bon vous
voulez pas dévoiler son nom on le
comprend mais ce qui est fascinant vous
vous êtes solidarisé totalement du
mouvement me too vous dites je ne
comprends pas toute cette femme qui
attendent 30 ans pour soudainement
accusé dénoncer leur violeurs au risque
de choquer j'en ai ras pardon j'en ai
ras la touffe du mouvement
et compagnie
et c'est drôle les vous avez été victime
de ces choses-là Catherine Deneuve Fanny
Ardant Adjani toutes les ancien les
actrices d'une autre génération
justement sont un peu contre Mewtwo
aussi alors qu'elles l'ont vécu et
celles qui sont plus jeunes et qu'ils
vivent moins sont pour j'ai du mal à
comprendre en fait si c'est parce que je
pense qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'excès avec
Mitou c'est-à-dire je pense qu'il y a
plein de filles qui étaient peut-être
pas forcément contre une aventure avec
des gens bien placés qui ensuite ont dit
oh il a voulu me violer et cetera alors
qu'en fait bon c'était peut-être pas
exactement ça donc je pense qu'il fait
beaucoup d'excès mais il est bien
évident qu'une fille qui se fait
agresser etc il faut essayer d'absence
vous vous avez été violé vous le dites
non j'ai enfin je sais pas été violée
j'ai eu des attouchements quand j'ai
fait une petite fille pourquoi pourquoi
vous n'avez pas porté plainte
réseaux
un animateur de de radio célèbre
comment à 8 ans
parce que en fait c'était le voisin de
mes parents ah oui ah d'accord d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai une vraie question sur le meetou
vous dites et j'entends je suis content
de l'entendre aussi un petit peu vous
osez dire ce que personne ne veut dire
parce que sinon c'est massacré j'ai
aussi des filles qu'on en profiter qui
était très jolie que les une chambre
d'hôtel on est d'accord c'est une
évidence alors après bien sûr on dit Oh
[Rires]
la phrase
[Musique]
c'est vrai que c'était quelqu'un
d'extrêmement important il me dit tu le
feras plus de cinéma et c'est vrai j'ai
galéré
retourne au mois d'octobre mais ça a
pris du temps oui parce qu'en plus une
fois qu'on a alors après c'est vrai que
vous le dites vous avez des soucis
d'alcool tout ça tout ça est réglé
maintenant mais c'est vrai que quand on
dit en fait cette fille-là méfie-toi pas
de promotion canapé elle peut dénoncer
et en plus elle est un peu fragile
terminé leur métier ça va vite est-ce
que grâce vous très honnêtement que vous
l'ayez fait ou pas fait très honnêtement
c'est une autre époque mais je crois que
je vous a jamais rien on vous a jamais
fait comprendre quelque chose on vous a
jamais non ou alors je m'en suis pas
aperçue
jamais mais
avec un regard je peux refroidir
un acteur il faut embrasser un peu il
brûle une énorme pelle et ça fait marrer
tout le monde quelque part déjà ça vous
pouvez lui mettre une claque où vous
pouvez qu'est-ce qu'on fait quand on est
une femme vaut mieux le mouvement MiTo
vous deux puisque Sophie Darren ça
l'agace un petit peu Catherine Deneuve
aussi c'était un peu tout ce côté
laissez-nous aussi avoir le droit d'être
dragué avant le droit d'être aimé c'est
vrai qu'on a pu si je vous disais vous
êtes très belle et que je viens
aujourd'hui vous embrasser sur la joue
sans vous demander vous consentement la
séquence sera coupée vous le savez ça
est-ce que le mouvement Mitou mouvement
Mitou pardon vous trouvez formidable
j'ai créé ma poésie donc j'ai pas
entendu
parler un petit peu quand même
franchement
en fait c'est la protection vraiment des
des actes qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
grâce vous aujourd'hui mais je suis un
peu comme chena je j'apprends voilà
écoutez les filles
on s'intéresse à plein de choses mais ça
on est passé à côté c'est vrai et est-ce
que vous regrettez un autre question il
y en a est-ce que vous regrettez parce
que vous avez du cinéma évidemment vous
êtes tourné avec des gros acteurs vous
avez fait beaucoup de cinéma plus jeune
notamment de longe aussi
formidable
et est-ce que il y a pas un moment où
vous avez peut-être regretté un petit
peu en disant si j'avais été un petit
peu moins stricte non non
faut pas s'asseoir un peu sur ses
valeurs ou c'est moi qui fait des
valeurs
c'est hors de question non franchement
ça va vachement choquer quoi d'accord
bien sûr que ça non je vous parle de
quand vous vous sentez dragouiller parce
que c'est vrai que on parlait de
producteurs Sophie à Cannes le nombre de
producteurs qui ont dit viens dans ma
chambre à minuit on parlera du scénario
augmente la crise soit totalement
étudiante
a parlé de ça vous savez que tous les
chambres dans au Festival de Cannes etc
deviennent des bureaux donc en vrai une
chambre n'est pas une chambre juste pour
dormir ou faire je ne sais quoi quand
la chambre c'est un peu les bureaux qui
font mais si si c'est les champs qui
font fils de bureau
une bouteille de champagne
un contrat avec M6 ou C8 pour un doc
Mathieu justement je pense que c'est ça
la limite en fait c'est un peu pas
évident pour je pense pour une jeune
comédienne pour une jeune actrice de se
retrouver on parlait de la famille tout
pour la fermer tout mais c'est avec One
Chine et c'est très intéressant il y a
justement un film qui vient de sortir
qui s'appelle she said sur les deux
journalistes qui ont mis voilà à jour
qui ont percé à jour cette affaire et
qui ont dénoncé avec des roses McGowan
avec gwynet paltro avec etc toutes ces
femmes là qui ont dit bon bah voilà
comment c'est comporter un des grands
producteurs de Miramax donc ça a
commencé comme ça et j'imagine bien que
quand on est quand on est avec Dieu le
père parce que c'était Dieu seul et
qu'on a 20 ans ou 25 ans et que le type
nous dit bon bah voilà tu vas voir
évidemment
de toute façon les filles pardon
un petit peu parce que tu es là tu es la
fille la vie est née de d'Isabelle mais
c'est très intéressant mais qu'est-ce
que vous dites aux actrices aujourd'hui
les nouvelles actrices qui elles le
dénoncent beaucoup et les états
américaines qui le dénoncent il y en a
pas mal même pour des séries des séries
télé aussi tout le monde tout le monde
dans les médias sont touchés tu étais
tout chez toi moi j'ai essayé de coucher
mais ils ont jamais voulu non mais bon
sérieux Benoît c'est vrai mais pour le
coup c'est sérieux
bah non mais c'est vrai tu es sérieux là
quand même il y a des filles qui qui se
prennent les mains sur la cuisse et si
elles le font pas elles ont plus de
boulot pour bouffer toi tu me dis j'ai
essayé de coucher avec quelqu'un
il continue les bougres non mais pardon
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez passer comme
deboratoire à la parole mais peut-être
comme message aux jeunes actrices
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
au revoir au revoir terminer rideau
je pensais par exemple à certaines
actrices comme la Seydoux Adèle
exactoulos qui ont dénoncé par exemple
des manières de faire aussi de certains
réalisateurs par exemple Kesh qui refait
faire la scène 50 fois de vas-y je te
dois je te mets on se non mais c'était
ça parce que c'était de lesbiennes elles
étaient en train de faire une scène
d'amour avec voilà et le baiser et on va
le refaire 45 fois à un moment donné
pour on parle de Vanessa Paradis dans
nos blanches aussi où elle a vécu ça je
pense j'ai pas comédienne mais je pense
que c'est difficile quoi la limite de
dire non de dire bah non en fait moi
j'ai pas envie de retourner la scène
pendant trois heures j'ai pas envie de
rouler
une question après je vais l'oublier
mais
si à vos enfants filles
elle vous disent maman je vais être
actrice quand vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
il y a du harcèlement qu'il faut parfois
coucher que c'est très dur de vieillir
quand
il fait des films une fille à 45 ans
comme des loups vous donne un rôle de
grand-mère et se termine aussi
il y a moyen de profiter de ce que tu
dis parce que bon j'ai la chance de
faire les quatre derniers films de
Jean-Pierre Mocky il ne m'a donné que
des contrats des moches des grosses des
des
mais quel bonheur oui ben ça lui mais
voilà grande gueule mais quelqu'un de
bien il était pas mais grandeurs
[Musique]
alors Sophie qu'est-ce que vous diriez
vous aux jeunes actrices aujourd'hui ou
jeune fille de télé aussi pardon parce
que ça existe à la télé
moi c'était la SFP donc je vais même pas
dire combien je dois gagner à l'époque
parce que c'est un gag quoi quand même
mais pardon Sophie mais vous trouvez que
ça a changé moi je veux dire quelque
chose dans ce qu'on adore vous êtes
mieux payés quand même non mais c'est
pas une question d'argent donc ce qu'on
appelle le fond dans ce qu'on appelle le
fond de grille on voit des filles
Faustine Bollaert tout ça mais sur les
gros prime le soir c'est toujours des
mecs éventuellement il y a une fille à
côté toujours
parce qu'effectivement la fille doit
être jolie en fait voilà c'est toujours
pas normal donc c'est vrai que c'est les
mecs qui ont toujours les problèmes ça
c'est sûr en revanche pour les
journalistes il y a beaucoup de femmes
journalistes mais voilà merci
c'est vrai que
dans un autre domaine c'est quand même
les mecs quoi il y a rien aujourd'hui il
y a des gens que vous auriez aimé
dénoncer parce qu'ils ont une vie
incroyable en faisant du mal à des
femmes que vous auriez dénoncé et vous
l'avez pas non franchement je l'aurais
fait si j'avais trouvé devant une
situation comme ça oui
c'est pas du tout le mot ce qui est
étonnant
vous et Isabelle vous avez l'impression
de parler de viol comme de rater un
autobus à 8h le matin
et puis et puis mais bon une fois que le
mal est fait
l'éternel phrase complètement con là ce
qui ne tue pas rend plus fort mais il y
a quelque part quelque chose de ça ok
bon
même pas exactement la même chose que
d'être violée oui mais Sophie on est en
2023 et c'est vrai que vous avez un
discours qui est touchant mais dès que
ça touche pas c'est déjà quelque chose
aujourd'hui on peut se permettre de ne
pas dire ça c'est pour ça que je les ai
à la main tu vois moi aujourd'hui par
exemple toutes les trois je vous adore
il y a 10 ans je serais venu faire un
bisou dans le coup de grâce de Capitani
parce que
parce que parce que c'est les sous-doués
c'est toute mon enfance et je vous aime
je le ferai pas maintenant ou alors je
vous demanderai l'autorisation
non non
mais c'est vrai que l'histoire de la
Belle au bois dormant qui doivent couper
la scène parce qu'il lui fallait
mais ça c'est ah oui
par tout ça un peu léger etc depuis tout
à l'heure mais disons quand même aux
jeunes filles et aux jeunes femmes que
ce n'est pas parce que tu ne cèdes pas
que tu es rayé à vie et que tu ne
pourras plus jamais rien faire
à l'époque vous avez une Sharon Stone
par exemple quand elle tournait Basile
kit et qu'elle avait ça ça qu'on voyait
cette scène avec la culotte elle raconte
que elle raconte que tous les hommes ont
été invités à regarder la scène alors
qu'il n'avait absolument rien à voir
avec le film c'est à dire les avocats
les hommes du ménage les hommes
absolument tous les mecs étaient là et
elle a un peu tapé du pont sur la la
scène a été un peu adoucie parce qu'elle
était un peu plus hardcore à la base et
elle a fait une carrière de de fou
jusqu'à maintenant donc j'entends ce que
tu dis mais pardon j'aimerais quand même
rappeler quelque chose parce que c'est
un problème dans l'oreillette on me dit
c'est un sujet important mais je viens
de rappeler quand même que grâce de
Capitani à qui je viens de demander
qu'est-ce que vous diriez de jeune fille
vous m'avez dit ne cédez jamais c'est le
message parce que je suis pas sûr que
tout le monde est bien entendu on prend
pas ça les légères du tout oui moi je
vais poser une question à grâce de
Capitani je me suis toujours posé à
propos de promotion canapé parce qu'à
l'époque vous avez dénoncé dans une
comédie certes mais vous avez dénoncé
quelque chose de d'inacceptable comment
ça a été pris à l'époque c'est à dire
comment la société les hommes surtout
ont été quel impact oui parce que ça
existait en fait je vais dénoncer
quelque chose qui existe
on a fait on a fait des entrées
incroyables mais oui mais genre on est
sur un sujet quand même se sont senti
concernés oui je ne sais le plus jeune
de mes deux fils me demande enfin maman
pourquoi tu as fait ce métier d'abord
moi je ne me qualifie jamais d'actrice
mais de comédienne et je lui ai répondu
pourquoi j'ai choisi ce métier
pour être quelqu'un d'autre
quelqu'un d'autre il faut ajouter
virgule et être respecté c'est très
important les signes de toi
c'est de faire apparaître un autre
personnage c'est sûr que Natacha dans
les ripoux elle parle pas comme la
Célimène dans le Misanthrope
on est d'accord tout ce que j'essaie de
faire sur ce plateau c'est de dire parce
que vous avez l'impression de dire tout
ça appart Fiona qui est plus brutal et
qui dit moi tant pis pour le cinéma tant
pis pour mon rêve tant pis pour ma
carrière mais non pas Saran comme on dit
on ne sait pas ça m'a permis de me
mettre les voitures
mais même question pourquoi ne pas
parler plutôt
c'est les 30 ans qui te pose problème
bah non non
a eu peur malgré tout de certaines
représailles à l'époque
parce qu'à l'époque moi je viens de
cette époque-là
où les 30 ans des viols c'est
que le côté un peu pardon Sophie
pourquoi on attend 30 ans bah parce que
psychologiquement c'est bien sûr
franchement je pense qu'il faut pas
laisser passer ce message pardon de le
dire parce que les filles qui sont
violets elles peuvent passer 10 ans 15
ans sans parler elles ont le droit et
quand elles ont envie de parler elle
parle donc le viol c'est autre chose là
c'est autre chose c'est l'époque tous
les mecs voulaient coucher avec toutes
les filles mais c'est ça la vérité c'est
en sac Mitou justement à libérer la
parole il y a un avant mytho et vous
savez c'est le principe Sophie de la psy
pardon mais c'est qu'il y a un moment
donné moi je l'avais très courte j'ai vu
un premier psy pendant 10 séances je lui
mentais je vous ai un one man ouais
et puis un jour je me suis dit il était
très gentil mais dit maintenant on
arrête le sketch dites-moi voilà vos
pires ont dites-moi tout je suis là pour
ça vous avez violé quelqu'un vous avez
fait et là tout d'un coup vous mettez
des mots sur l'horreur et j'ai vu que
moi aussi depuis 10 ans les mots que je
ne mettais pas et que j'ai mis donc le
viol tout ça c'est pareil c'est pas un
truc qu'on va à la police
intérieure on le reconnaît pas on le dit
ce que je
je l'ai même pas dit à mon ex-mari c'est
seulement le monsieur avec lequel je vis
aujourd'hui à qui je l'ai dit mais sinon
c'était encore pour moi une honte je
n'osais pas en parler et ben voilà c'est
ça ce que je veux entendre Sophie pardon
fais de le dire
comme ça c'était l'époque ben non il y a
pas même si encore une fois on ne juge
pas ces gens parce que c'était une autre
époque et tout ça mais malgré tout c'est
que malgré la honte malgré la
culpabilité vous restez victime voilà
bah oui bien sûr qu'ils choisissent de
se taire
avait été extrêmement on va dire goujat
avec vous disons qu'il était très très
énervé mais ça je sais pas c'est très
mauvais avec vous dire ça donc
c'est-à-dire que j'étais en tournée avec
lui j'étais toute minette j'étais avant
que je fasse de la télé et tout ça je
présentais son spectacle et il m'a dit
écoute il faut absolument que tu viennes
dans ma chambre j'ai un nouveau système
de purificateurs
je dis tu crois et tu me dis si si je
t'assure tu vas voir c'est un truc
complètement
j'avais 25 ans un truc comme ça
et donc je suis allé visiter dans sa
chambre avec son secrétaire et à partir
de ce moment-là il a demandé au
secrétaire de partir il m'a jeté sur son
lit avec des intentions assez précises
et moi j'ai pas voulu en fait j'ai ça me
disait rien du tout je sais pas j'avais
pas envie j'ai dit oui à d'autres hein
je suis plus je suis plus vierge mais
lui je sais pas il y avait bon et là ça
a été vraiment je disais au secrétaire
reste là Claude lui disait casse-toi et
cetera enfin bon finalement je m'en suis
sorti et ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'après comme j'ai démarré la télé et
je l'ai vu plein de fois je le
présentais tout ça et il avait beaucoup
d'humour parce qu'il me disait tu sais
finalement j'étais le meilleur coup de
ta vie tu aurais dû accepter tu sais pas
ce que tu as raté etc
Sophie non mais parce que il y a
beaucoup de pudeur chez vous et c'est
vrai il veut il faut bien expliquer aux
gens encore une fois c'était une autre
époque et que à cette époque là on se
posait pas des questions c'est le fameux
Michel Leeb que je veux inviter ici qui
veut pas venir parce que le pauvre il
était tétanisé maintenant parce que on
veut lui parler de du sketch de
l'Africain il y a 30 ans on a riait tous
donc
c'est vrai
non mais voilà c'est pour vous dire que
on ne juge pas les gens c'était une
autre époque mais ce que je voudrais
dire Sophie c'est que
Claude François vous met sur un lit
essaye de faire des choses avec vous
vous réussissez à quitter la pièce tant
bien que mal vous
faire engueuler
à mes parents j'étais avec mes parents
ont râler puis pour aller
ou sans plus il n'a pas violé quoi il
voulait mais il a tenté
de en tous les cas il avait pas de
purificateur